- And what was happening in
that scene? Was that a sinkhole?
- That was.
- That's my worst--not my worst nightmare.
It's definitely in the top three.
- Yeah, no. I didn't have that
fear until I did the show.
And then I was like, "Oh."
Don't do research into
it. Do not do research.
- I have. I have Googled
the hell out of it
'cause it happened in Florida
and I was like, "Wait, what?"
I was like--no, it
happens. It just happens.
- [Zyra] Yeah, I don't like that.
- Yeah. And you just don't know.
Yeah. Anyway, it terrifies me.
That will give me nightmares
for at least week.
Yeah, for at least a week.
Okay. Well, there's other
things that will happen
that will probably give me nightmares.
- Probably.
- But you're the first amputee to star
in a primetime network
show, so that's pretty cool.
It's amazing.
(audience cheers) Yeah. For
a lot of people who think,
"Oh, I can't do that" or it's
not the norm, or whatever.
That's amazing, that you get
to be the pioneer of that.
- See, I've never felt like that.
None of my family is like that.
Their like, "You're fine.
Come with the rest of us.
You still have to carry things."
Like my mother, growing up, she was like,
"Alright, I'm gonna give you muscles."
And so I would be the one to
carry all the grocery bags in.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- Even after I had my leg cut off,
she was like, "Alright,
grocery bags, let's do it."
- Oh my God, I love that
though. It pushes you.
- [Zyra] Oh yeah.
- Yeah. Oh, and I make my
kids do that stuff, too.
I'm like, "You don't even
pay rent, so grab something."
(audience laughs)
- If you don't pay rent, you
have to carry grocery bags.
- Well, you have some special guests
who came to support you, right?
- I do.
- Can you point 'em out for us?
- Right there.
- Right here? Yes!
(audience cheers)
I love that. So wait, you got into acting
because of your limb difference. Right?
- Yeah.
- So how? Like why?
- So before that, I
wanted to be a mortician.
- Is that real?
- Yeah, that's real.
- I love that.
- I'm not kidding you. I
wanted to be a mortician.
- You could still play a mortician.
- I could.
- Absolutely.
- [Logan] If you can be on this show,
you can be whatever you want.
- I feel you like, you
gotta do research into that.
Then it's basically, like,
getting your degree. Right?
- [Cynthia] You can do it.
- I had my leg cut off, right?
And I was like, "I wanna inspire people."
Which now makes me, like,
inspire grosses me out now.
The word 'cause everybody
uses it for like,
the littlest things or like...
- Oh, I love the word inspire.
- Okay, but use it in a different way.
People use it on amputees and their like,
"You picked a flower.
You're so inspirational."
- Oh, well okay. I gotcha. I got you.
- [Zyra] Nothing inspirational,
just living life.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I was like, I wanna inspire
people. I wanna be a model.
I'm gonna show people you
can do whatever you want.
And then I went out, I got an agent.
And she was like,
"Alright, we're gonna
send you on acting things
'cause you gotta big personality."
And then I just kept
doing them and doing them
and I was absolutely terrified.
Like I would get violently
ill before every audition.
- Did you ever turn
around and wear a hoodie
and like, hide yourself.
- There's no shame here. No shame.
- [Zyra] I respect that. I respect that.
- But those moments mold
us. They build character.
That's what I've been
told by my therapist.
- Yeah, for sure. It's the
trauma, it makes you funny.
- Yes, it makes the humor.
You gotta find humor.
So I heard you have a
certain tattoo. What is it?
- I do. It's on my foot.
I would show you, but--
- Then you have to take it all off.
- Yeah, it'd be a whole thing.
So, when I was in the
hospital, right, 13 years old.
We have a really sick sense of humor.
And so I have one foot in the grave
written on my leg in
permanent marker by my aunt.
And so I was in Australia, right,
and I was like, "I wanna get a tattoo."
'Cause it's Australia,
I wanna do fun things.
And so I had her send me her writing.
One foot in the grave and I
got it tattooed on my foot.
- That's actually very sweet.
And inspirational.
- [Zyra] Inspirational.
- Inspirational.
- I was goin' for sick humor,
but okay. That works too.
- But that's inspirational.
It's like finding the humor in that.
I love your family.
Your family is awesome.
- [Zyra] My family is great.
- Do y'all have any tattoos
that mean something?
- Oh, no, no, no.
Lynda Browning would not
let me get any tattoos
and I still am afraid of my mother.
- Do you have any?
- [Marque] I got two.
- You've got two?
- Can't show you all of 'em.
I'm just kidding.
One here on my arm,
was actually done my friend
who just passed from COVID.
- [Kelly] I'm so sorry, but man,
what a beautiful thing to have.
That legacy on your arm from, yeah.
- Yeah, it says, "Breathe.
This too shall pass."
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And then another one that's
over here. It doesn't matter.
It's like sun rays and space and whatever.
(audience cheers)
- Oh, that's cool.
- Inspiration, all the things.
- I love that.